hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played uh i believe
two years ago in 2020 i was an online
match between vaseline vancouver and
alireza a first ja even though i've
written alert so sorry about that let me
just quickly fix that uh yeah uh between
uh
vasel and alireza and um
uh well in this sunday the the seventh
leg of the melt weather champion chester
will start is the the julius bear
challenge and it will feature some very
very strong players very interesting
players uh amongst them uh vassel and
alireza or here are all of the players
if you guys are interested so magnus
duda like
uh
christopher yoon and also the winner of
the npl india indian tour elect three
was supposed to play but narayanan said
that he uh already uh
promised that he would
play play some league so he he will not
be joining so probably arawind will take
his place or uh if he can't do it
probably someone uh someone else i i
don't think it was announced just yet
but yeah of course everyone is waiting
for the carlson versus niemann clash but
until that happens uh we will have some
very nice clashes between uh some of the
legends like evan chuke and girlfriend
will take on the youngster sergey si uh
kymer uh there's pragananda christopher
yu so it's gonna be very very
interesting and i thought i'd
show you a game that was played
between between the two of them they
played the match they played the 10 uh
10 rap or maybe there were 10 blizz
games i don't know there were 10 rapid
games i think online and in the end the
result was five five and then they
played one more game it was a blizz game
sort of a tiebreaker and this is that
game uh so let's check it out it's uh
super funny as uh vassell sacrifices two
rooks for no apparent reason uh now
let's dive straight into it as as chuck
usually does
uh so here
a vassal opens with ponte e4 uh we have
e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and now
bishop to b5 uh vassal goes for the rui
lopez with a6 morpheus defense pilot is
a bishop to a4 and now pawn to d6 we
have c3 and the bishop to d7 the modern
chinese defense
we have d4
g6 and now bishop to g5 so i've been
played before nothing new uh even in
2020 we have f6 bishop back to e3 and
the bishop to g7 we have castles by
vassal knights the h6 and now pawn to h3
taking away the g4 square from alvarez's
pieces uh we have castles and now there
is one game from 1989 between patrick
wolfe and gatakonsky where queen the b3
check was played akamsky was able to win
that game but here
we have rook to e1 and it is now as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game
uh so let's see how alireza deals with
this position he starts with king to h8
and of course uh why wouldn't you you
are expecting this bishop to assume this
diagonal so better to have the king on
h8 so knight beat the d2 and now queen
to e8 all right we have bishop to b3 and
now pawn to b6 we have d captures on e5d
captures and now knight to c4 and okay
vassal has some very very impressive
setup here the knight's putting pressure
but as long as this f6 e5
setup stands the knights will not be
able to do anything against this e5 pawn
so he will probably move the knight move
the queen he will double up brooks and
the d file and alireza will try of
course to withstand this so here we have
g5 and knight to h2 gaining more control
over the g4 square
rook the d8 aligning the rook with the
queen and now queen of course goes to e2
first we have queen to g6 now putting
pressure on the e4 pawn and pawn to f3
uh vassal just defends it with knight to
f7 and now rook a to d1 we have bishop
the c8 offering a trade of rooks and now
bishop to f2
uh knight the e7 uh and knight the e3
and you can see uh that uh vassal is
starting to control more and more
squares he controls d5 he controls f5
the bishop is controlling this long
diagonal uh of course there's a tension
on the d file if if black trades white
gets dirk on the d file and and vice
versa so here knight to d6 and now
rook to d2 alireza doesn't want to trade
but that means that uh of course russell
will take this opportunity to double up
rooks and the d file a5 we have rook e
to d1 and now rook d back to e8 uh he
does not want to contest um
the rooks on the default so he switches
the rook to the e file and now comes
rook captures and d6 and this is the
first uh
vintage vassal move uh
here for example if this was a rapid or
or or classical game you would play
something like g4 and you would say okay
you have no moves i control all of the
squares here look at my rooks here uh
controlling this entire d file the
bishop slicing all the way here the
knight controlling d5 controlling f5
this knight can come to f1 to g3 and
then to f5 to h5 uh there's really
nothing for black to do here but it's a
blitz game uh so vassal plays rook
captures on d6 we have c captures on d6
rook captures and e6 so uh he he or he
he he did sacrifice some material but he
won a pawn and now he's going to win the
other one too so rogue d8 and the rook
captures on b6 so now uh he already has
a past c pawn
uh we have queen to e8 biologist now
comes pawn to a4 uh making sort of a
safe haven for the rook on b5 and here
bishop the d7 now the queen and bishop
are attacking the a4 pawn and again
there's really
like any move
makes is a good move you can play a
queen to c2 to defend the pawn you can
play knights to d5 if you want to play
attractive moves uh batavasa plays rook
to b5 so he gave up the first rook for
some uh
blitz counter counterplay and now he
gives up the other rook for some uh
blitz counterplay which is uh well only
one of the reasons why we love uh vassel
so much and here uh alireza could grab
it right away but he doesn't he first
plays rook the b8 uh he he thinks it
would be too dangerous to create a pass
pawn uh so c4 vassal says all right you
can take it any way you want i will have
my uh pass pawn and i will play a captus
and b5 that will create a pass b pawn
and a pass c pawn that's already there
so knight to c6 and now knight to d5 we
have pawn to f5 valida
and e captures on f5 bishop captures on
f5 and now bishop to c5 attacking
galleries as rook and f8 so here comes
knight to d4 attacking the queen if
bishop captures then of course you're
very happy your rook will no longer be
attacked queen back to d1 and now knight
captures on b5 this is how well it is
that captures the
uh the uh the second rook and he keeps
his bishop pair so a captures on b5 now
uh vassell has the two connected past
pawns and pawn to e4 uh alireza wants to
break through and make use of those
bishops and rooks so bishop to d4 now
countering the dark square bishop queen
d7 and here we have pawn to b6 we have
bishop captures on d4 queen captures
with check and now alireza blocks with
the queen not afraid of the two
connected past pawns and vassal says all
right let's do it queen captures on g7
king captures on g7 and now knight to g4
and it seems like the two pawns should
be unstoppable but
let's see what happens e captures on f3
we have g captures on f3 and now bishop
to e6
uh vassal says not a problem
i'm just gonna play c5 the knight is now
nicely defended and the my pawns are
marching forward so here rook captures
an f3 luckily it comes with an attack on
the bishop so first we have to tend to
the bishop bishop to c4 and now bishop
captures on d5 very very precisely
played by alireza bishop captures and
now rook to f5 not allowing the pushing
of pawns as the bishop here is hanging
and here vassal plays knight to e3
defense the bishop attacks the rook and
now is ready to push his pawns to
victory
and
there is only one move all it is i can
play here in order to actually win the
game uh so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this maneuver
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to uh
spot this one congratulations and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is rook to e5 now of course that
you see it now it's very very simple you
are just attacking the defender of the
bishop on d5 and then you will start
collecting pawns so it's a simple idea
but you know when you're playing uh
blitz you you might miss it but alireza
of course spots it and now the problem
is the real problem is if you defend the
knight king to f2 which of course you
guys have calculated then rook beat the
e8 attacks the knight and now uh
uh russell would have no moves here
there's just no more you can make knight
is hanging if you move the knight to the
bishop is hanging and of course uh if
you do nothing let's say bishop sorry
let's say bishop to c6 attacks the rook
uh then rook f8 check and once the king
moves then just rook caltrans on c5 and
of course the pawn will never promote as
it lands and on the dark square you have
a light square bishop so this is
completely winning for alideza so
instead after rook to e5 avassa said uh
all right you can have your knight pawn
to c6 and okay rook captures an e3
already accepts the challenge pawn to c7
we have rook eat the e8 and now sorry
rook e to e8 this is the
uh the idea because if now you captured
the rook here let's say it promotes to a
queen rook capture cereal and b7 uh you
will never promote this pawn it promotes
on the dark square and of course uh
there there's no uh point in playing
this so after rook e38 uh we have pawn
to b7 first advancing the pawn all the
way now we're getting ready to capture
the rook but now alireza just played
rook beat the c8 another brilliant move
and of course he was in this position on
move 47 that vasily manchuk resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so it seems like you know when you have
two pawns on the seventh uh you know you
are used to your opponent resigning the
game but here you can see nicely that
even with the bishop uh the the two
rooks are able to stop the the two pawns
because now uh what do you what are you
gonna do of course if you promote this
pawn it doesn't matter we just capture
captures bring another queen real
captures and the end game is completely
winning for uh alireza and if you don't
do this what else can you you can
capture the rook but still just throw
captures and this is now going to fall
it's on a dark square of course you
cannot defend it uh so yeah uh very
nicely done by by both of them
uh vassal playing in absolute great
style sacrificing both of those both of
those rooks but maybe it was uh you know
a tiny bit too much and alireza was able
to take this one with some brilliant
defensive maneuvers and then just
finding unique moves to take the full
point
uh and thus winning the match of course
if you guys are interested in the other
games i will put uh all of the games
there's a
there's a study unleashes with all of
the 11 games so it will be the first
link you see in the description below if
you guys want to check that out uh so
yeah i thought i thought this would be a
nice um introduction into the into the
hulu's bear generation cup
so we'll see some some interesting games
to be played there uh eddie grace is
playing magnus in the first round i
believe
uh so should be very very interesting if
magnus shows up i mean no one no one uh
has seen magnus since uh
since that whole uh fiasco
in the sinkhole cup uh but yeah we'll
see what happens or should be should be
a nice event uh so yeah and that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
sometimes when you sacrifice a rook
maybe don't sacrifice the other one as
well uh just because it's you know cool
and and looks awesome maybe you know try
to
try to win the game rather
uh so yeah once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
abdul rahman al-swad uh kariel elise
rodella uh lucas del caris simon osborne
and paul sultanovich for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the chess world uh the
uh the multiple champions gesture starts
uh on sunday uh thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day